so it's really very exciting to talk
about you know exciting things you know
happening in Microsoft but the reason we
actually create cognitive api's is
really for our developers people like
you so it's really exciting for me to
see innovative use of those API is by
our customers and the partners I'm going
to introduce to partners come coming up
very soon but I want you to talk a
little bit about our language and
translator API
so one of the most interesting things in
artificial intelligence is really
understanding human language we believe
that he is the reason why that the human
species have advanced so much in the
last several thousand years if you think
about that there are thousands of spoken
languages right now in the world it's
just so so difficult for us to have
enough time to learn too many languages
so in Microsoft when we started
Microsoft Research 25 years ago the
first group who actually ever studied
was a natural language the second group
who we started was speech recognition
computer vision group was one of the
first of five groups we started you see
we have invested in those areas for a
long long long time so we really want
you focus on natural language because
it's important for us to help to break
down the language barriers for so many
people you know around the world so
today we actually put all the
technologies behind Skype a translator
and the Microsoft translating the app
the technology now becoming Microsoft
cognitive services translate a API so
without the first view I'd like to
introduce Lars to come to the stage Lars
is the the executive vice president of
tele2 which is the large mobile
operating in Europe they actually have
50 million customers in nine different
countries Lars is going to show us some
very exciting demos
and how they can use the application
okay Lars Thank You Harry and it's a
great pleasure to be here
being participating in the build
conference and contributed to the build
conference as well
what is tell to or who are we at tell it
to we are actually challengers and I
sometimes say we are one of the last the
challengers in in the operating space in
Europe and we've been challenging since
day one
we began with challenging monopolies
cracking them open making communication
services available for everyone and we
continued to do that across and recently
we've been challenging outdated pricing
models and now with the translator API
come across we found a common challenge
actually together with Microsoft to be
able to to bring this translation
service alive a technology taking it
alive not just to the few but to the
masses to be able to create a speech to
speech translation service that actually
was that could be work full for for
everyone I actually have a good friend
of mine he's French and he he doesn't
speak that well English actually and
that perfectly honest my French is not
that great either so we have a little
bit of an issue when we try to
communicate with each other so we
actually was thinking about putting this
translated API actually to the test so I
was thinking to just give him a call and
see how it's doing
are you there all of your colonial qahal
radius villa just after 1200 years of a
simple ah
yes I'm here I hope all the trying to
turn around for you great actually a few
friends
soup air is just reason fed killed cuz I
mean I say also well don't just swap or
pom are they are perfect I'll see you
tonight for a drink pretty awesome and
that was done with no new hardware no
new apps it just works
and how did we do it we integrated the
Microsoft translator API into our
network and that added a lot of benefits
number one it works across fixed
telephony as well as mobile telephony
and on top of that it works across all
kind of devices so your own dial phone
at home your feet your phone and also
your smartphone no apps needed that is a
great service now why are we doing this
rather me telling you all about that we
actually put a little video together for
you
more than 6,000 languages are spoken in
the world today no wonder people
everywhere is struggling to get on when
they simply can't understand each other
the human race can no man on the moon
but we still can't talk to the person in
front of us so our company decided to do
something about it together with
Microsoft their program understands what
people say and it translates your words
into another language and we can make
that work on your phone in real life so
when you speak your language the other
person hears the translation right after
your voice then it works the other way
around when that person speaks we hope
this will make life easier for millions
in fact we are planning to offer it to
some people who need it badly right now
this summer we hope refugees in Europe
will use our service to start building
their new lives getting in touch with
authorities looking for work or
accommodation and so on and we will
start rolling it out in different
countries
this is tele2 and Microsoft trying to
make things a little better for everyone
so the next step for us we are really
excited about we will take the service
and as you know there's a lot of people
on the move in Europe right now looking
for a new country a safe house and of
course a big challenge then for European
countries today is of course to find
interpreters which has become a shortage
so what we would actually like to do is
to bridge that gap so we would like to
go to government institutions and help
them out and hopefully with this
translator service then be able to
enable everyone to communicate without
any borders we call it democratizing
communication I'm going to be here today
to give my team and I know there's
plenty of other use cases that we would
like to share and I hope that you take
the opportunity to discuss with us and
continue the conversation together today
as much as possible thank you thank you
very much Lars this is very impressive
you know just that you can see that the
power of cloud computing and with any
kind of phones and with some AI
technology here so the next up we have a
CEO of a startup company Flavio from
Brazil actually Flavio met with our CEO
sat here just a few months ago when sake
of is the Brasil made a bunch of
promising startups and the CEOs that's
when we actually got to know in a very
interesting work by love you ice
actually not seen those one from one
spoken language to another one is
actually from spoken language to sign
language to help you people with hearing
difficulty come out
Thank You Harry it's my pleasure to be
here with you
my name is Flavio I'm from I'm
co-founder from pro-death and we have
this solution our mission actually is
breaking the communication barrier
between deaf and hearing people so maybe
you don't know but there are more than
350 million deaf individuals in the
world and most of them are illiterate
which means writing writing
communication is not an option
in fact 40 49 percent of death of
American deaf are unemployed and to
solve this problem we create where we
have created product suite a suite of
products who translates spoken language
into sign language using a 3d character
let's take a look
okay
hello how are you today
now let's imagine that you want to
communicate with a deaf person while
travel in about the country for instance
I'm from Brazil I speak Portuguese and I
want to communicate in American Sign
Language let's see what you can help
with this
no samus own and mudada video - pursuers
that's it Portuguese to American Sign
Language and how it works it's very
simple the Microsoft sales data API
sends the translated text the product
server receives it and sends a set of
sign language instructions to our 3d
avatar on client side so very easy I'm
very excited to be here and to present
you this better version of product
communicator because this is only the
first step to help empower those
millions of deaf individuals in the
world and in fact breaking the
communication barrier if you have any
question it'd be my pleasure to talk to
you after this sessions like this
session thank you so much for your time
and thank you Microsoft and Zeta team
as really a very inspiring work by
Flavio and his team